John Smoltz Major League Baseball
Network analyst he's a hall-of-famer
Red Sox Yankees started three game
series tonight John in the booth for the
game and they you know here we are over
the final stretch drive obviously it's
talking about Bob Seger in the Silver
Bullet Band this is their last tour just
announced what was your first concert
you know I'm a pretty extravagant guy
there Dan I don't go to a lot of
concerts when one one my first one ever
was James Taylor I think I've been to
two maybe three tops but James Taylor
was backstage and I'm not a concert guy
I just not I don't like a lot of people
in one area did James Taylor know who
you were
he was performing in Atlanta I sure hope
so I I hope so I I didn't really meet
him I knew the touring manager at the
time and so I'm gonna go on record and
say he had to know of me see you're
claustrophobic oh no no no not at all oh
I just I just don't like a lot of people
in my same area when I'm either trying
to watch something or you know this
I don't mind performing in front of a
lot of people I just you know rather be
in my own comfort simple what is that
like though when you're in a World
Series and you got 50,000 people there
and you're on the mound I think can you
get used to that
yeah I'll say this if you if you think
about or even look at 50,000 people then
you're not going to have a good game but
you get used to it knowing that that
you're performing you know your
performance is going to be viewed as you
can't be oblivious to it but you try to
get into a tunnel and that's the best
way I can describe the way all my
postseason games Rose me to catch her in
the hitter with an occasional bullpen
session in places like here Yankee
Stadium where they get you laughing or
get you you know they're they're
professional hecklers and
areas so they they know things about you
that no one should and that can get you
off your game a little bit but once you
get on the mound and in what environment
what was their go-to line to maybe make
you laugh I remember in 96 was pretty
good it was getting ready for Game one
of the World Series and you know you try
not to listen to a lot they're yelling
at you the right anja of course that was
at old Yankee Stadium so that was a
little bit more of a but one guy yelled
out I think you played the accordion
[Laughter]
laughs because that's actually true you
are an accordion factually true that's
right and so they they they I don't know
if you know they did their homework
and they were trying anything they could
you get to the dugouts and if you make
eye contact to see with people a booklet
I got I mean they're yelling screaming
it you don't want to do that you kind of
kind of play it off
and you try not to pay attention to all
that in in the in the dome however it
was so loud that you know having a
conversation was was very difficult I
don't want to run down some things here
so and and we'll get to some of these
matchups the Dodgers certainly doing
their best to survive there in the West
but your American League MVP candidate
who is going to be the MVP well you know
what that's that's that that MVP has
been stretched in so many ways and
definition terms like what does it mean
what numbers do you value I'm gonna say
this you know more than likely JD
Martinez is not going to win the MVP but
the fact that he's not being mentioned
as high as he should be or even if even
as a close second is a little
disappointing to me because of all the
nuances and the new analytics that just
don't value you know certain things that
for history baseball has always valued
as important RBIs for one they discount
it like it's some kind of non-essential
statistic so it's going to come down to
Mookie Betts and his ability to do more
than just play offense
obviously a great defender Ramirez and
Lindor I mean that the American League
is exciting
in every way with with the intrigue of
the national league sayang because of
the strangeness of how that's going with
only 150 done in 60 innings of sale but
I'd say the slight edge is going to be
mookie betts but I I'm a big JD Martinez
does more than people think
type player right stuff you can't
quantify stuff he's done in the
clubhouse changes the mindset that the
hitters universally changes the lineup
the fact that he doesn't play defense I
don't hold against him it's not like
he's replaced Big Papi and that's why
Boston's having the year they're having
that's why it even helps some Mookie
Betts to have him in the lineup I would
go with Ramirez you know this is an
all-star third baseman moved to second
base he's a 34:30 guy I think the fact
that he plays for Cleveland he's not a
guy that's ever gonna be featured he's
not interviewed a lot um you know I
don't think he's going to win it
but that would be the guy I would take
National League MVP who would you take
wow I mean that that's just as hard I
think you've gotten guys that have had
stretch runs that in and of themselves
if the season stopped at any particular
point you'd hand it to Baez or you'd
hand it to carpenter you know the fact
that Goldschmidt to me had such a
horrific start yeah and and everyone
just I can remember everyone in the
baseball world said this is sad like
this is embarrassing so bad for him he's
lost his way
oh really just turned it up to a naught
and R and again he's like the most
underappreciated superstar in our game
and I just love watching him play I
think he's thrust himself because of the
other guys kind of lag I mean whether
it's Baez getting a little bit tired or
carpenter hit a little wall but I think
Goldsmith has thrust himself up there
along with guys like Freddie Freeman
just mister consistency for Atlanta so
it true it truly will come down to the
last two weeks of who
can regain their form or stay hot
because it is very difficult to do what
Paul Goldschmidt did in the end grin
really Matt Carpenter for that matter
they both lost their way and went on
just tremendous stretches yeah I'd
probably get to Javy Baez he's played
second and sure our third and short he's
done that to make up for injuries there
so that at second and short and third
for the Chicago Cubs I'd probably give
it to bias where are you right now I'm
in the Yankee Stadium I'm gonna be here
for the foreseeable future
dan I'm here for a long long night a
game that started that one's gonna be
played at 7:00 I hope all because of the
weather
yeah oh boy yeah can you go run on the
field can you slide can you go out and
have fun do anything I've already helped
I've already helped the grounds crew you
thinking about back here the the food
room I'm gonna help with this chef I'm I
think I'm a pretty good sous chef I've
got a lot of things I'm gonna make
rounds and just see who I can help I'm
gonna be an advocate today instead of
you know the bitter guy that walked in
here at 9:30 and got to do a clock
digging good thing I'm not on Twitter or
social networking today would not be a
good day probably so I'm looking at the
positive preparing to do in the future
it's your 5 to 5 tool player yeah you
know all right let me start handicapping
here the best race if you if you looked
at it now handicapping the best team in
the National Angus ooh gosh that
question I've asked everybody for the
last two weeks and nobody likes
answering it because they can't feel
good about it right I mean you've got
the surprise of the Atlanta Braves and
and all that they've done that division
has kind of been really under under you
know when the Lawson Nationals don't
play up to their potential of course it
comes down to the Atlanta Braves and
Philadelphia Phillies and Billy had just
gone backwards at the wrong time I still
if press 2 if press 2 having to pick
that one team that I feel King can
represent the National League
I've said it for the last month I'll
probably stay with it it would be the
Los Angeles Dodgers the roster that they
possess every team internationally has
weaknesses and every team could get
exposed really quickly you know you look
at what Chicago is lost in their bullpen
you look at what Ellie's bullpen has not
been and Janssen lost temporarily so
there's definitely holes the scariest
team in the National League to me is
same as team that scary in the American
League and that's the bullpens of
Milwaukee and Oakland now neither one of
them look like they're gonna win their
division although you know Milwaukee
still could and that one game playoff it
makes it very difficult to play the
Milwaukee Brewers with their bullpen and
the Oakland A's with their bullpen so
from the National League standpoint with
all the competitive balance that still
has to be played out and there's no sure
thing other than maybe the Atlanta
Braves looks like they have the easier
path to the playoffs so to speak with
their lead I would go with the Dodgers
and their experience and what their
roster kind of control at you Red Sox
are the Astros in the American League
dad is gonna be you know if they get to
play each other
which a lot of people feel they that in
the future baseball should re seed based
on the collision course of let's say the
Red Sox and the Yankees right away
versus in the past you couldn't play
your own wild card winner in your
division but if the Red Sox and the in
the Astros play that is going to be a
series for the ages because of what each
team can do to the other you know you
look at you look at what the Red Sox and
their new manager Alex Cora saw from the
opposite side when he was the bench
coach with the Astros he's already
infiltrated some changes that have made
the Red Sox better because what he saw
from afar he was able to go and say this
is what Isis is what you guys exposed to
us he's made those changes they can run
well the Astros went out got a throwing
catcher and Maldonado to try to squelch
that the I say the Red Sox and the
Astros are similar in every way with
maybe the exception of their bullpens
they can run they play defense they're
starting pitching is hot
now and their offense can be chin in
different ways so that to me is is a
series that everyone I'm sure
Cleveland's not looking forward to and
the Yankees or Oakland is not looking
forward to because they can interrupt it
you have a problem if Jacob degrom wins
this I own no I no not at all ok no no I
think we're seeing the best pitchers
internationally he is this year and I've
always been a fan you know ever since I
did his first game I always felt like he
would rise above the rest of the group
that was a you know a very talented
group that looks like again next year
they'll be one of those favorites
because the quote will be if they're
healthy the New York Mets have a chance
to could make a deep run but what Jacob
degrom has done this year and some
people are going to say you know didn't
pitch a lot of important games team was
never in it I get all that but to pitch
27 consecutive games of three runs or
less baseball in today's times is is
about as impressive as I've seen in my
entire career baseball and you know
short of her shy Hershiser improbable
scoreless streak you know this is this
is about as impressive as it gets and
what's going to be interesting for me is
how they judge and view Chris sales here
which is one of the most dominating
years but although be at only 150 155
innings and you're gonna have pitchers
that pitch 60 more innings than he does
that I think are equally as deserving if
not should get the award for that amount
of work that they put in you know I
think that has a lot of value and snell
year and in Tampa is just second to none
as well yeah that's been a very
surprising season for him but a big win
total alright have fun
maybe get a nap there at Yankee Stadium
and we'll be I might not be watching
tonight I'm not gonna lie to you I mean
I might be I'm just not sure I
understand if it was one o'clock
are you watching but I 7 expire I just
don't know I got Entertainment Tonight
to watch I got I mean I got I got other
things to watch well I understand that
well think about this I throw this at
you
Cory - Mike you might be you know at one
o'clock I was probably going to do a
prototypical broadcast at seven o'clock
who knows what's going to come out of my
mouth
right so maybe they're saying maybe
there's like you want to see how grumpy
I might be or where I might go or you
know it's a little intrigued now it's my
first game ever done in a booth with you
know 13 hours of prep well okay if you
give me a shout out or the show like if
you say earlier today when I was on the
Dan Patrick show if you do that in the
first two innings all right I'm gonna
I'm gonna watch and I'm gonna plug the
hell out of this thing but if not I'd
just okay you got it I got it I'm
writing it down right now in my notes
earlier today 26 hours ago I was on the
Dan Patrick show and we talked about the
value of JT Martinez and it's amazing
that he's been overlooked and I'm
surprised because he's flirted with the
Triple Crown and he may lose out to his
own teammate mookie betts who he's made
better by being in the lineup something
like that oh that's all getting on the
air I could probably see right now that
went to the top of my nose
you can watch John and hear John tonight
Red Sox Yankees starting at 7 o'clock
tonight three game series Major League
Baseball Network John good to talk to
you again you're talking to Dennis hi
buddy for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show ass
[Music]